hi my name is Lilith my name is Ryan and
today we'll be presenting on our summer
camp experiences good morning everyone
my name is Lilith my name is Ryan and
today we're gonna be talking about our
wolfram summer camp experiences so just
a little bit about myself I'm currently
a senior at Torrey Pines High School
which is located in San Diego California
and some of my interests include math
coding deep learning and neural networks
and I love playing basketball and tennis
so how I got introduced to the Wolfram
language was and when I joined the
computational thinking Club which Miss
Brown just spoke about last year in 2017
we do a lot of stuff in this club as
you've probably heard we do like a lot
of graphing not only math stuff but like
basic machine learning and a lot of
various different folks on a lot of
various different subjects and so due to
this computational thinking Club and
Miss Browns recommendation I was
fortunate enough to attend the wolfram
summer camp with Ryan and we did a
project there and we had a lot of fun
and learn a bunch things and so focusing
on the machine learning aspect I learned
the basics and the computational
thinking Club and I this was where I was
exposed to it so we did a bunch of like
stuff on classify and we did like with
like mythological creatures and stuff
and out and so Ryan and I presented and
another student at our school presented
a project on this because we were really
interested in machine learning so in
conjunction with our calculus PC class
we used we did a project on the
classification of infinite series
particularly geometric series and P
series and this used a simple binary
classification and the inbuilt neural
network that Wolfram has and so just an
example of the data set we created is as
you can see the images are just P series
in geometric series and I think we had
like 75 images of each in our data set
and we train the classifier on these
images and as you can see if you do like
the probabilities and input a picture
you can see it's like a pretty skewed
answer you could that's like 100 - what
0 and that's because it's pretty easily
you can differentiate between the data
set like there
distinguishable and so going on to the
summer camp so I was inspired to learn
more about neural networks and after I
prefer we presented at the annual math
open house at our school so one of my
friends actually had a really
interesting topic at mat at the open
house and after I looked at that I was
just like oh my god I have to learn
about machine learning in neural
networks and so in the first two weeks
of summer I learned like I watched a lot
of YouTube tutorials and like on what
neural networks were and how they worked
and like it was just so intriguing and
so we for the next two weeks of summer
from July 1st to 14th Riya tended the
wool from summer camp and over here we
got a lot of exposure to the Wolfram
language and it was just a very good
experience as you'll hear and so during
the first week we met a lot of the other
students we had a bunch of similarities
and I think it was that allowed us that
allowed us to mingle pretty easily and
our interest allowed us to like converse
a lot and learn a lot about each other's
us like interest and so during the first
week we had like three lectures per day
just cuz everyone needed to be on the
same level and it was like a lot of on
the basics of Mathematica and how to use
the basics functions and like the syntax
and all that stuff but movie yeah and so
we they put us all in the same playing
field because so be hard to say
knowledge on it and we also had to think
about our projects and what we'd do over
the next week and so my first first
project was inspired my dad and his when
he was a child his main source of income
was agriculture were farming when he
lived in it he when he was born in India
and lived there and so my first trace
project was what type of plant would be
best suited for an environment given the
type of soil air temperature moisture
and all like a lot of information but I
quickly came to realize along with with
the help of the mentors that it would be
a really complex project to work on
because the data is really hard to find
and it would just be like complex
overall after being
getting to the Wolfram language it would
not be pretty good to like work on an
intense project off the bat and so
during the second week we had two
lectures per day and these were more
specialized we had like lectures on
neural networks blockchains and various
other topics which were individualized
and we also had a lot of time to work on
our project as well because these
products were very hard for us and like
being intros or being like you know
introductory to the Wolfram language it
was like kind of hard to get started in
all that stuff and but uh in comparison
to that we also had a lot of fun
activities we would play like Ultimate
Frisbee they had pool tables and table
tennis and all that stuff so it was like
really fun along with the hard work we
put in so moving on to the main part of
my presentation my project so my project
was classifying ten different types of
font text which is basically so I would
get an input of a picture of words and I
would tell I try to tell what type of
font type was used for example Arial or
like Algeria and so to begin off we knew
we needed a data set for this and I
needed to question how we would get this
data set so what I did was I created a
list of out the alphabet both uppercase
and lowercase and some of the special
characters be used in our sentences and
I associated this weights with how they
were used in the actual English language
and I created a training set which would
basically create an image of randomly
formed letters but with how they were
rated in the English language so if you
go down and you could see a picture of
just an example of what a picture looked
like in the data set and so the next
step was finding neural network that
would pertain to this data set and being
an amateur to the Wolfram data
repository or you own that repository I
didn't know what they were basically but
I just took a random one which was the
atom X Abnett and I soon came to realize
it was not a good choice I immediately
ran to an error because like every time
I tried to train a neural network it
would exceed the memory of my laptop and
it would just crash the kernel every
single time and me being lazy I would
never save my work so I just had to read
it over and over again and yeah I
realized that I had to save my work and
yeah I don't yeah for some reason you
can't see the architecture but you guys
are just gonna have to believe me on
this one
so atom X app is like a really long
neural network it has a bunch of layers
and requires a lot of computing power to
Train so after getting help from my
mentor and a couple of other mentors I
realized that this was not the right
neural network to use because its main
objective is to determine the main
object in an image for so for example
like a cheetah or a spoon but I was
trying to recognize the font type in an
image which there like two completely
different objectives and so I moved on
to take inspiration from the Linette
Linette neural net whose basic objective
is to find the recognizer digit in a
picture and so I realize this was pretty
similar task to what I was trying to do
and so I took this but I modified it a
little bit and if you go down again I
can't show the architecture for some
reason but Lynette had two convolutional
layers and two pulling layers which do
most of the work and I'll explain it
more but yeah and my my neural net had
three convolutional layers three bloom
layers just a little bit more different
tasks and I guess more intensive in some
way so what the convolutional ailes do
layers do are basically they're like
feature extractions so like the and they
perform matrix multiplications so at the
beginning convolutional layers you
basically have like the general
structure the general features of the
image and moving down if you have like a
bigger neural network they would go more
into the specifics like for example the
features of face or the features of like
a hand for example and the pooling
layers are basically down sampling the
image they take the maximum number in a
given matrix size and move it onto the
output and so yeah after doing this I
came to the conclusion of the data set
was pretty unrealistic because I tried
to like just take a screenshot of an of
a word for example and try to input it
into my neural network and it gave me
the incorrect answer so now I was
questioning I was on the under the
question of what I should do next so to
make the data more representative
of what an actual user would try to do I
took screenshots of different font types
of articles in different font types and
so this was just an example of what one
screenshot looked like I had like six to
seven of these for each font type so it
was a lot of data and then I put the
help of my mentor if you go down I
created a function that takes a random
segment of the image a random 120 by 120
pixel segment of this of the image and
it creates as many an N number of
segments that you want so that's just an
example of from the above article that
function creates a function outputs and
so I generated 6,500 images for my data
set and I this successfully I got a
pretty good accuracy of ninety nine
point six nine percent however I
realized that it was overfitting and
that I need to do something about it
so if you scroll down that's just a
picture of like what my training looked
like and yeah you could see that the
loss is pretty low which translates to
the error being low for the round and
the validation is what I tested the
neural net on and the error is lower
than the round error which is pretty
good and so I tried the I tried to test
the neural net on the picture I showed
above and that it actually so you can
see the probabilities there and it those
are all the font types I tried to use in
my neural net and you could actually see
that it gives the correct output which
is Algerian so however I realized that
the neural net is only successful when
used in conjunction with like the same
type of data it was trained on and it
has trouble recognizing data in any
other format so for example if you just
tried to crop out like an image of a
word itself and tried to input it into
the neural network I don't think you
would work out that well
so although the functionality is pretty
limited and in has trouble recognizing
the image I realized that with the right
type of data set thus Neil and I could
do like whatever you want it to so in
the future I hope to improve on this
neuron that by getting like different
variations of images
and using different like and augmenting
the data so Daniel and I could get more
used to various types of data and even
like used sentences or separate words or
like bold or italic variants to try
manual nap and so next slide so just
concluding the summer camp it was an
awesome experience and I learned a lot
throughout this it opened up a bunch of
doors for me and like the machine
learning and neural net like subjects
and after the summer camp I put a lot of
effort into learning more about neural
networks what actually goes inside and
the algorithms and all the stuff that
like intrigued me just inspired me to go
on and on and to learn about them and so
those are just a couple of pictures we
took at the summer camp it was an
awesome time and I'll pass it on to Ryan
who's gonna talk about his experience
all right I'm also a senior at Torrey
Pines High School located in San Diego
California and I was first exposed to
the Wolfram language in the year 2016
this was the year that my teacher
decided to start the wolfram workshops
at our school and this focused on the
fundamentals of the Wolfram language and
I was fascinated by the power of the
Wolfram language and I started to learn
about it on my own time
and because of this I was able to finish
a majority of the elementary
introduction to the Wolfram language
book so next year I transitioned over
the club transitioned over to the
computational thinking Club which
basically focused on the applications of
computer science and I thought it was
cool that it was possible learned pure
high-level computational thinking
without being forced to deal with the
lower-level mechanics of coding and with
my experience in the computational
thinking Club I Lincoln and I and one
other person presented up the map open
house out here and this was the classic
kitchen of the infinite series that
looketh already talked about and with my
interest growing I decided to attend the
Wolfram summer camp this year Wolfram
summer camp was located in Boston and it
went on for two weeks and so generally
the daily schedule of the camp would be
or in the morning time we would have
around two hours of lectures focusing on
the
friend language itself and during the
afternoons we would have a lot of
project time and in the evening we would
have lectures for our mentors and guest
speakers on various topics such as
machine learning cryptography
cryptocurrencies etcetera and I like the
concept of learning by doing
which you could directly apply what we
just learned and getting creative with
these some of these topics which would
have been harder to do in a lower level
programming language which is held down
by the mechanics / details of the
language and so for project selection we
were given a repository of around 70
ideas and we were asked to pick on
around 3 from the repository and
proposed two of her own and then from
there we would have a one-on-one meeting
with Stephen Wolfram to decide which
project we would be working on for these
next two weeks and so the project that I
was selected to work on was a personal
proposal of mine and with this we were
also assigned a mentor who was an expert
in that field and the project that I
worked on for these two weeks was the
boy sentiment classification problem and
so the goal was Golden's project was to
be able to take an input of Audio speech
file and be able to classify that into
one of the eight different emotional
categories using machine learning and so
to find the data
I used the Ryerson audio-visual database
database of emotional speech which I
found on cable and with this law and
this consisted around 1440 audio files
voice actors saying various sentences
and phrases and different emotional
tones and with this large file I
separated this into eight classes with
the respective emotional categories and
I threaded them to their titles and this
is a representation of the data after
had it has been encoded and this is the
Mel spectra on or after I encoded the
data I put it in the convolutional I
have an architecture of the
convolutional neural network here and
this basically extracted some of the
features of the spectrogram and after I
extract these features I then inserted
into the kernel now which recognizes
them the patterns in the image
and for the results I was able to
achieve an accuracy of around 85% and
this is the confusion matrix plot which
displays and I created a microsite which
I tested some of my own audios and see
how it works
conclusion yeah it was a great
experience and I was able to explore
sophisticated computation ideas in the
club and with and I gained a lot of
practical experience with computer
science in general and I applied that
experience to internships and work
experiences additionally my interest in
machine learning and neural networks
grew from this as well and these two
weeks helped me connect with students
with similar aspirations and thank you
we'd also like to thank our mentor
Michael Kaminski who helped us a lot
with our project and he knew a lot about
neural network so thanks for that and we
have several mentors over here and would
like to thank you for for organizing
this and you know helping us grow our
aspirations and motivate our interest
and your own that works in machine
learning if you have any questions I can
verted into a spectrogram because I
wanted to insert the images into the
convolutional neural network which would
because I thought it was easier for the
ComNet to recognize the some of the
features individuals and by putting it
the recurrent net it would be able to
recognize some of the baddest yeah yeah
of course so we had like a couple of
guests yeah we had a couple of guest
speakers um that would introduce like
these different topics to us which we've
never heard of so it was like we got a
lot of exposure to different things but
the main lecturers helped us focus on
what was like what we needed for the
camp and it helped us learn the basics
and it was just like it was it was very
important it was like an integral part
of what we did at summer camp right cuz
we were basically introductory students
to the Wolfram language and reapplying
to learn more I stayed yeah
I guess we went overtime for a couple of
the lectures and like if you could be a
little more time constraining or
organized I guess that's that's all I
have otherwise it was like an awesome
experience yeah yeah oh yeah sure so uh
don't answer that okay so yeah a
computation it was the computational
thinking Club allowed us to get our
first exposure to the Wolfram language
so Ryan actually did Wolfram workshops
one year before I got to know about the
club and now we're leaders in the club I
guess and so it gave us like an
introduction to the language we I'd had
no prior coding experience myself but
I'm not sure about Ryan and it since
wolfram mathematica is pretty like
intuitive language you can understand
the concepts by like the functions
themselves and you could see like how
they work and so I think it was a pretty
good introduction to myself and Ryan
do you have any forum
yeah so I'm at the club itself we do a
bunch of activities and Miss Brown posts
the activities on her website if no
one's available to check it out so we
have like her website as a resource and
if you missed out we could email them
with the activities and a lot of stuff
so we have outside resource yeah yes no
we did not that's an interesting topic
but yes yeah it's definitely woodworking
yeah yeah definitely thank you yes in
99.6% I actually have no idea I guess we
would have to do further study used to
collect data from how people recognized
fonts and how often they recognized
fonts in order to compare the data I
have for my neural network two years for
example yeah I have no idea any other
yes yes I'd love to teach anyone about
you own that works yeah not as much as
we did at the bull from summary can any
other questions yes sir
sorry
oh yes I actually created another neural
network which recognizes plant seedlings
and like yeah we have different classes
of plants and so I created it was like a
dataset on kaggle which I brought down
and I create annual Network for that so
yeah I didn't worked on my own projects
after the summer get into so yeah if
that's a thank you for your time and we
hope you enjoyed our presentation
[Applause]